la pratique des fichiers et du fichage
est ancienne mais sa magnifique sa
massification et sa banalisation
interroge et peut-être sur les raisons
pour lesquelles nous avons demandé
l'inscription de ce débat ce soir ici au
sénat alors que la france a longtemps
été un pays où la protection du droit à
la vie privée était très forte
on glisse vers une acceptation voir la
certitude que la multiplication des
fichiers nécessaires
ainsi en octobre 2018 le rapport de
l'assemblée nationale sur les fichiers
de police dénombre près de son psy
fichiers pour la seule police vise à la
disposition des services de sécurité
contre 58 en 2009 face à ce mouvement
effrénée de création de fichiers de
récolte de données personnelles dont la
finalité est lusage réel interroge nous
avons donc souhaité l'organisation de ce
débat
en effet nous assistons je les dis à une
banalisation de l'uja lusage
gestionnaire des fichiers par l'ensemble
des administrations pour rationaliser
les politiques publiques renforcer la
dite maîtrise des coûts ou encore
l'évaluation des activités des agents
avec la généralisation du travail par
objectifs chiffrés ainsi que tu as une
radicalisation du contrôle social la
création à 78 du fichier safari a
entraîné la naissance de la cnil censé
être un garde fou les créations des
fichiers edvige ou base élèves en 2008
ont fait l'objet d'une véritable levée
de boucliers
mais aujourd'hui la multiplication des
fichiers dans l'objectif de surveiller
contrôler et réprimer des populations
sont réels contrôles parlementaires se
fait dans l'apathie générale
pire on accumule ses données dans une
logique prédictive et non préventive
et pourtant les fichiers sont une
maltraitance à un outil de
déshumanisation d'objective isation les
fichiers ne peuvent pas prendre en
compte les singularités les spécificités
de certaines situations de certains cas
individuels
dans ce sens le fichage tente à nier la
complexité humaine
le fichier devient un outil de gestion
administrative on confie donc à des
machines des tâches qui devrait être
fait par des personnes avec leur
conscience leur savoir-faire leur
capacité d'appréhender des situations
particulières que le ce que l'on songe
aux fichiers pôle emploi créé d'abord
pour les demandeurs d'emploi cet outil
sert en réalité à traquer les chômeurs
et à accélérer leur radiation un service
aussi sensible où l'on connaît les
problématiques d'électro nisme où les
difficultés particulières ne peut être
sous traitée à un ordinateur
que dire encore de la création d'un
fichier de personnes vaccinées alors
qu'un fichier du nombre de vaccins
disponibles et de leur utilisation
aurait permis un meilleur contrôle ici
un meilleur contrôle de la politique
vaccinale de l'état ainsi il y à une
chosification des gens mais aussi la
volonté de normes et les comportements
il ne s'agit plus de poser des interdits
mais bien d'imposer un comportement
celui que l'état définira comme adéquat
à cet égard la volonté de ficher les
manifestants et syndicaliste relève
moins de la lutte contre les inégalités
que de la volonté de discipline et les
fractions de la population les plus
indocile
car ce savoir ficher ou surveiller
empêche l'action empêche la pensée est
donc l'expression de la démocratie
c'est dans ce cadre que la
multiplication des fichiers police et de
surveillance sociale à des fins dit
sécuritaire nous interpelle et j'ose
dire nous inquiète plus particulièrement
d'autant que ces derniers peuvent être
basés sur des critères de suspicion de
culpabilité et de dangerosité incertain
ils sont de ce fait susceptibles de
violer la présomption d'innocence le
droit au respect de la vie prix
et ainsi que le droit à la protection
des données personnelles clair ces
fichiers sont souvent faux ainsi par
manque d'actualisation ou des erreurs de
saisie une personne disculper peut
continuer à être enregistrés comme
dangereuses dans un fichier de police
les données saisies peuvent être mal
enregistré une personne devient auteur
d'une infraction alors qu'elle est
victime
et la liste n'est pas exhaustive or ces
erreurs peuvent difficilement être
corrigé lorsqu'elle se propage au
travers d'interconnexion entre fichiers
de police à ce titre l'interconnexion
des fichiers complexifie le droit à la
rectification
or peu à peu la sécurité a été érigé en
droit en lieu et place de la sûreté il
ne s'agit plus d'assurer la protection
du citoyen et compris contre l'état mais
de faire de la prédiction de menaces
nous sommes bien loin du droit à la
sûreté
défini par les articles 2 et 17 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
site web pas un mois sans qu'une
nouvelle idée du fichage ne sortent des
bureaux du ministère de l'intérieur en
février c'était jour note une
application qui facilite la collecte de
photos et d'informations sensibles
religion politique sexualité prétendu
origines sociales raciales et leur
transfert dans des fichiers extérieurs
tels que le thé aj qui permet la
reconnaissance faciale ou encore le
détournement du fichier du système de
contrôle automatisé automatisé pardon
est celle qui a pour objet de conserver
des informations relatives aux délits
routiers et qui depuis avril dernier
sert de base pour traquer les
informations relatives au non respect du
conflit
que dire encore de l'utilisation
illégale des drones et des possibilités
de reconnaissance faciale des
manifestants or cette multiplication des
fichiers de police
ce fait dans la plus grande opacité et
surtout bouillie la séparation des
pouvoirs et la répartition des
compétences entre le parlement et
l'exécutif
le constat fait en 2009 dans la mission
d'information présidée par delphine
batho est toujours d'actualité
l'exécutif lorsqu'il entend donner une
base juridique officier de police qu'ils
crèvent peut toujours recourir soit à la
voie réglementaire sur le fondement de
l'article 26 de la loi du 6 janvier 78
soit à la voie législative
ainsi rien n'interdit au gouvernement de
créer un nouveau fichier de police par
décrets ou arrêtés et de facto se
soustraire du contrôle du parlement et
nous pensons que cela doit changer
ainsi en 2009 29 27% des fichiers
n'avait fait l'objet ni d'une
autorisation légale ou réglementaire ni
d'une déclaration à la cnil
en 2011 il y en a il y en avait 81 ans
recensés et 45% entre rester dépourvues
de base juridique
qu'en est il aujourd'hui car c'est dans
ce cadre alors que la problématique est
connue que le gouvernement a adopté
plusieurs des cris pour autoriser
l'identification automatique et massive
des manifestants voire la reconnaissance
faciale
cette autorisation s'est passé de tout
débat démocratique comme le cil et le
souligna quadrature du net
c'est encore par voie réglementaire que
le 4 décembre dernier
trois décrets permettent d'étendre les
informations recueillies par les
services de police en a affiché qui ont
été créées sous la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy
la prévention des atteintes à la
sécurité publique la gestion de
l'information et prévention des
atteintes à la sécurité publique et les
enquêtes administratives liées à la
sécurité publique à travers ces fichiers
les services les à travers ces fichiers
par dont les services de police pourront
recueillir des informations sur
l'opinion des personnes surveillées
opinions politiques publiques sont
philosophiques religieuses ou une
appartenance syndicale mais aussi
certaines données de santé ainsi que des
activités sur les réseaux sociaux le
tout pour des finalités élargie qui
dépasse la sécurité publique les nouveau
décret permettre d'aller au delà de la
notion de menace à l'ordre public qui a
fondé le patient est logique le gie
passe et le gisti nous alertent le champ
des personnes susceptibles d'être
concernés est ainsi très large
ce faisant il conduit à stigmatiser la
liberté d'opinion
l'action syndicale le fait d'être
adhérent un syndicat qui laisserait à
penser qu être adhérent d'un syndicat
pour être associée d'une manière ou
d'une autre à des impératifs de sécurité
intérieure de sûreté de l'état de lutte
contre le terrorisme et de violence
urbaine en 2011
une personne sur dix étaient fichés
qu'en est il aujourd'hui
qu'en sera-t-il demain pire c'est une
nouveauté les fichiers pourront aussi
concerner des personnes morales ou des
groupements
on imagine qu'il s'agira d' associations
des groupes facebook de squad de zad ou
même de manifestations enfin il ya une
extension du domaine de la fiche jusqu'à
présent les fichiers du pass ou du gip j
parce qu'on ne pouvait 10t l'entourage
de personnes dangereuses que de façon
succincte sur la fiche principal de la
personne dangereuse
désormais si la police le juge
nécessaire chaque membre de l'entourage
pourra avoir une fiche presque aussi
complète que celle des personnes
dangereuses et compris lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants de moins de 13 ans en
conclusion en 83 mireille delmas marty
s'interrogeant sur l'état autorité à
écrivait ceci l'état autoritaire n'est
pas nouveau ce qui est nouveau peut-être
c'est sa façon d'être autoritaire d'une
autorité grise
et pénétrante qui en valait envahi
chaque repris de la vie autorités
indolore et invisible et pour prendre
confusément accepté et pour reprendre
ses mots
ne laissons pas l'exigence de sécurité
briser le rêve de lille amérique merci
chers collègues dans la suite du débat
la parole est à monsieur max brisson
pour le groupe l'est républicain et pour
sept minutes chers collègues 1
présidente madame la ministre mais
chaque collègue le sujet de ce débat a
choisi par nos collègues sénateurs
communistes n'est pas de la vocaux prix
due au hasard et trop sa source dans la
parution au journal officiel le 4
décembre 2020 de droit décret modifiant
le code d'un circuit intérieur au sujet
de trois fichiers de sécurité pu
notamment nous n'oublions pas que
s'intégrer en susciter de fortes
inquiétudes de la part de plusieurs
associations de défense des libertés qui
redoute s'il fallait le résumé que
nouvelle étape de soient franchies en
matière de surveillance de masse de nos
concitoyens à cet égard je souhaiterais
ce soir que nous temps durs
collectivement de prendre un peu de
recul sur cette question d'autant que
l'essor des fichiers n'est pas au
phénomène qui serait raisonnable de
qualifier de récents rappelons nous du
bertillonnage et au 10e siècle s'est
largement développée afin de
rationaliser et techniques policières
d'identification notamment par la
constitution de vastes fichiers
contenant des données corporelles
nombreuses catégories d'individus
délinquants criminels vagabond individus
soupçonnés d'espionnage ou anarchistes
et nous apparaît dès lors pas incongru
que les progrès technologiques change le
visage de ces fichiers de sécurité
publique
en premier lieu s'était créé 2 décembre
dernier procède en réalité à une
modification du cadre légal afin de
prendre en compte l'évolution de
pratique déjà employée par nos
différentes forces de sécurité
intérieure ce nouveau cadre juridique
était nécessaire
c'est indiscutable
mais il traduit en creux un besoin
opérationnel avérés s'il fallait le
rappeler ces fichiers ont notamment pour
finalité la protection des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation
on nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
d'être naïve la menace terroriste
demeure encore élevé dans notre pays
en second lieu le conseil d'état le 23
décembre 2020 a jugé que lesdits
fichiers ne portait pas une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté d'opinion
de conscience ou de et de religion ou à
la liberté syndicale en raison de la
limitation par le poids réglementaire de
la collecte et de la collecte et de
l'accès aux données concernées au strict
nécessaire pour la prévention des
atteintes à la sécurité publique ou à la
sûreté de l'état
dès lors mes chers collègues je crains
que certains d'entre nous nous prennent
pour de la peur ce qu'il est autre chose
qu'une angoisse si la peur porte sur un
sujet déterminé l'angoissent est une
étude vaincre l'angoissé la réalité de
la liberté parce qu'elle en est le
possible creek et rien dans le concept
angoisse en 1844 aussi plutôt que de
nourrir une crainte des mesures et chez
les français notre rôle en tant que
parlementaire et de montrer le chemin
vers une plus grande confiance dans nos
forces de sécurité et dans leur
professionnalisme
l'extension du contenu de ces fichiers
ne peut être envisagée a priori comme la
porte ouverte à des dérives qui si elles
se produisent parfois sont isolés
condamnable et dûment sanctionné par
notre loi pénale une telle conception ne
serait pas rendre justice au dévouement
à la déontologie et à l'éthique de nos
fonctionnaires policiers et gendarmes la
confiance nous nous interdit pas bien
sûr de nous interroger
ainsi s'agissant du fichier des enquêtes
administratives liées à la sécurité
publique qui facilite la réalisation de
khat administratives lors du recrutement
d'agents publics à des postes sensibles
le gouvernement avait répondu à une
question écrite de madame la députée
duriez en 2010
que les données enregistrées dans ce
fichier était entourée de garanties
renforcées
le mieux serait d'ailleurs expliqué
ainsi que dans les domaines politique
philosophique religieux ou syndical
ce ne sont pas les opinions des
personnes mais leur seule activité qui
peuvent donner lieu à l'enregistrement
et ceci uniquement dans les cas où leur
comportement pourrait porter atteinte à
la sécurité publique
vous savez incompatible avec les
fonctions auxquelles elle postule car il
est désormais car ce n'est désormais
plus le cas et la collecte ainsi
autorisé peut se révéler plus
attentatoires aux libertés qu'elle ne
l'était auparavant
se pose donc la question de savoir si en
matière de collecte
les agents candidats un recrutement qui
n'ont pas le statut de vocoder bénéficie
des mêmes garanties que les titulaires
par ailleurs qu en est il exactement de
l'interconnexion
autrement dit du rapprochement ou de la
mise en relation de ces fichiers avec
une ou plusieurs autres bases de données
en effet l'état connexion n'est pas sans
incidence
qu'il s'agisse d'atteinte à la vie
privée de droit à l'oubli ou encore de
présomption d'innocence
enfin l'un des enjeux qui doit être au
coeur de nos préoccupations et la quête
d'une rigueur toujours plus exigeante
dans le recueil et la conservation des
données en danger la fiabilité des
fichiers est un gage fondamental de
confiance entre l'état et ses
administrés aussi quels moyens le
gouvernement mais qu'il en oeuvre pour
s'assurer de l'exactitude des
informations que l'administration
rassemble qu'elle contrôle permettent le
cas échéant de prévenir ou de corriger
des erreurs de saisie dans les
conséquences peuvent être lourdes pour
nos concitoyens tant qu'elles sont du
point de vue des sénatrices et sénateurs
des républicains les questions qui se
posent madame la ministre
et je vous remercie de bien vouloir qui
répond merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur pierre jean
verzeaux laine pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
et pour cinq minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je remercie les élus
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologistes de mettre ce débat à
l'ordre du jour je souscris totalement à
l'intitulé respect des libertés
publiques protection de la vie privée
est nécessaire état des lieux des
fichiers dans notre pays on peut
légitimement s'interroger sur les
garde-fous et les limites qu'il faut
poser pour protéger les libertés
fondamentales des citoyens
pour autant je ne suis pas certain que
nous y donnons le même sens que nous
parlons des mêmes fichiers et que nous
poursuivons en la matière les mêmes
objectifs
mon collègue l'a rappelé le 4 décembre
dernier
trois décrets ont été publiés afin
d'étendre les possibilités policière en
matière de fichage le fichier de
prévention des atteintes à la sécurité
publique
le fichier de gestion d'informations à
la sécurité publique et le fichier lié à
la sécurité publique fin ce dernier
étant utilisée pour réaliser les
enquêtes administratives préalables à
certains recrutements dans la fonction
publique ces décrets ont été publiés à
la demande de la cnil et à la vérité
reconnaissons qu'il s'agissait là de
régulariser des activités qui existait
et des fichiers qui existait déjà
alors désormais le terme d'activité
politique ou religieuse sera remplacé
par le mot remplacera pardon le mot
opinions politiques convictions
philosophiques et religieuses pourront
être ajoutées des données de santé
révélant une dangerosité particulière
des troubles psychologiques ou
psychiatriques des comportements et
habitudes de vie
des déplacements des pratiques sportives
et les activités sur les réseaux sociaux
le conseil d'état la plus haute
juridiction administrative a rendu un
avis positif positif en amont et il a
confirmé sa position quand il a été
saisi par des organisations syndicales
après la publication des décrets mais
nous parlons de quoi ici de permettre
aux gendarmes aux policiers aux services
secrets
bref à tous ceux qui en charge la
sécurité des français d'avoir accès à
des informations les plus précises
possibles pour des personnes qui sont
susceptibles je cite de porter atteinte
à l'intégrité du territoire ou des
institutions de la république
d'ailleurs madame la ministre il serait
intéressant que vous puissiez nous
préciser combien de personnes cela
concerne en france
à ce jour le rôle d'un état c'est de
maintenir l'ordre public c'est de
protéger les citoyens et au maximum
d'empêcher le pire je vais pas rappeler
ici que traversons un moment où nous
sommes exposés au terrorisme islamique
aux fanatiques de tout genre et aux
extrémistes et que bien souvent ce n'est
pas d'un excès d'informations dont nous
souffrons
c'est un manque de renseignements précis
sur ces personnes
en ce qui concerne la protection de la
vie privée est un état des lieux des
fichiers
j'aimerais moi connaître les fichiers
que les google facebook
instagram amazon ont construit sur nous
qui sommes simplement des utilisateurs
de réseaux sociaux
pour le coup il me semblerait utile
voire indispensable que nous sachions
quelle est l'étendue de leurs
informations
comment il les stocke combien de temps
as qu'ils les vendent
comment sur quels principes
j'ajoute que ces groupes en matière de
sécurité intérieure on pourrait
d'ailleurs en attendre beaucoup plus en
terme d'information
voilà mon sens un enjeu essentiel de
notre société du vivre ensemble
c'est aussi ce qui nous permettra de
voir si la politique peut et se donne
les moyens de réguler
et enfin de contrôler l'action de sega
fin ne perdons pas de temps et prenant à
bras le corps ce sujet je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci la parole et fameux c'est paul
toussaint parigi pour le groupe
écologiste
cette solidarité et territoires et pour
cinq minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en france
comme dans les autres pays du monde la
lutte contre la crise sanitaire s'est
traduite par une limitation des libertés
publiques d'une ampleur inconnue hors
périodes de guerre au nom de la sécurité
individuelle et collective au prétexte
du renforcement des moyens de la police
sur fond de dégradation du climat social
et de lutte antiterroriste
ses griffes et à ce régime de sécurité
sanitaire un déploiement inédit de
mesures sécuritaires attentatoires des
libertés individuelles et des libertés
publiques
en somme un glissement insidieux vers la
confiscation des libertés fondamentales
de chacun d'entre nous or ce contexte
inédit est exorbitant du droit commun
nécessite est précisément qu une
attention vigilante soit portée à l'
équilibre subtil des piliers de la
démocratie à la juste proportionnée
alité entre sécurité des citoyens et
garantit les libertés fondamentales
comme préalable à l'exercice et
républicains si notre intention initiale
tend à protéger la démocratie
les nouveaux contours que vous donnez à
l'exercice du pouvoir
dessine un paysage ambivalent sorte de
panoptique géant on aux libertés sont
gravement menacés pire
l'emballement des réponses sécuritaires
en usant les libertés individuelles
nourrit le jeu de ceux qui souhaitent
ébréché les fondements mêmes de la
démocratie sous couvert de lutte contre
le terrorisme au nom de la sécurité
publique
vous prenez le 2 décembre dernier 3
décret élargissant largement les
possibilités de fichage et de collecte
d'informations
désormais tous les acteurs du monde
économique associatif et syndical
peuvent relever de ces fichiers pour les
personnes physiques des données
désormais autorisés à être collectées à
leur insu allant du parcours
professionnel aux habitudes 2
en passant par les déplacements les
pratiques sportives et la santé
psychiatrique relève d'une intrusion
inédite dans leur vie privée
comble de la surveillance vous autorisez
désormais les pratiques illégales en
faisant figurer dans ces fichiers
les opinions politiques et des
convictions philosophiques et
religieuses et non plus seulement les
activités politiques ou religieuses une
digue importante vient de tomber d'une
logique de fichage d'activité ont pas ça
c'est d'un recensement d'opinion où
chacun peut être fichés à raison de ses
convictions
c'est un acte politique gravissime
pourfendeur de nos libertés
fondamentales
madame la ministre comment dès lors ne
pas voir qu'une telle base de données
légaliser une intrusion policière dans
l'ordre du politique comme dans l'ordre
de l'intimé qu'elle entretient la
confusion entre militantisme déviance
voir délinquance en se nourrissant de
catégorie flou d'ailleurs dénoncée par
la cnil
cette base ouvre un champ d'application
visant autant le dire toute la
population cette base madame la ministre
mais leur à un peu plus ordinaire de
l'exception soul empire de la
présomption arbitraire dans ce qui sera
succès susceptible ou non de porter
atteinte à l'ordre public
autant de mesures qui préfigure une
société gouvernée par la peur dans
laquelle les citoyens seraient privés du
droit de penser de contester et qui
devrait en retour leur vie exposée sans
limite à la surveillance des forces de
l'ordre la liberté est un droit de faire
ce que les lois permettent écrivait
montesquieu attester que les opinions
puissent se représenter un danger en
elle-même démontre une rupture dans la
manière de penser la sûreté de l'état et
nous nous y trompons pas signe
l'avènement d'une société de contrôle
comment alors ne pas s'opposer à cet
arbitraire du fichage qui porte en lui
le terreau du totalitarisme assurer à
tous la liberté dans une nation libre
chasse et l'arbitraire faire affirmé est
sanctionné cette liberté par une justice
libre
voilà l'idée madame le ministre
que nous nous faisons de la démocratie
si notre groupe soutient les mesures
d'ordre public visant à protéger les
citoyens en accord avec les principes
républicains de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité
il est des principes intangibles trop
durement acquis auquel ne dérogerons pas
dans un pays qui se prétend attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs et à l'état de
droit
il est des actes que nous devons
collectivement refusé au nom de nos
histoires particulières au nom de notre
histoire à tous parce que le ferment de
notre liberté est celui de notre
humanité
madame la ministre la protection des
citoyens ne peut pas se faire au
détriment des libertés publiques
or vous ériger la des moyens de notre
futur asservissement que vous offrir à
quiconque voudrait donne à faire
basculer la démocratie michel foucault
écrivait en 1975 dans surveiller et
punir que le simple fait de savoir de ce
savoir surveiller entraîne une forme
d'obéissance les opinions d'el orfi chez
ses aveux le contrôle de la population
pour la mener vers une forme de docilité
donnant de facto à l'état le
monopolisation évidence légitime
aussi madame la ministre vous demandons
nous l'abrogation de ces propos car les
véritables partisans de l'ordre ont
toujours été les plus grands défenseurs
de la liberté et nous voulons croire
encore que vous en faites pas je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame nicole duranton
pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendant
pour six minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 2 de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
préfigurer la protection de la vie
privée qui a ensuite était affirmé en
1948 par l'article 12 de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme en
droit français
l'article 9 du code civil introduit par
la loi du 17 juillet 1970 dispose que
toute personne a droit au respect de sa
vie privée
l'article 7 de la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne
garantis ce même dans le féminisme
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a été
auditionné le 12 janvier par la
commission des lois au sujet de trois
décrets pris le 2 décembre 2020 et qui
avait fait polémique c'est dans ce
contexte que nos collègues du groupe crc
me ont inscrit ce débat ces trois
décrets concernant concerne trois grands
fichiers d'une part enquêtes
administratives liées à la sécurité
publique qui relèvent de la direction
générale de la police nationale et de la
préfecture de police de paris
il s'agit de contrôler la fiabilité des
autorités accédant aux sites sensibles
de l'état
d'autre part les fichiers prévention des
atteintes à la sécurité publique
pour la police et gestion de
l'information et prévention des
atteintes à la sécurité publique pour la
gendarmerie conserve quant à eux les
identités d'individus dont l'activité
peut porter atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état
intéressé leur public ou être en lien
avec des faits de violences collectives
contrairement à beaucoup de fichiers
souveraineté ces fichiers ont été
publiés ce qui garantit l'information
des citoyens et des parlementaires
ces trois fichiers ont été élaborées
entre 2019 et 2011 suivant des
recommandations d'experts puis contrôlé
sur leur principe par la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés la cnil en 2017 et en 2018
la cnil définit un fichier comme un
traitement de données qui s'organise
dans un ensemble stable et structurer la
loi de juin 2000 du 20 juin 2018
relative à la protection des données
personnelles dit qu loi rgp des a permis
d'en faire
cette démarche le conseil d'état a émis
un avis favorable
ce contrôle a priori a permis de les
valider qu'en est il du contrôle a
posteriori plusieurs associations et
syndicats ont demandé au conseil d'état
de suspendre l'exécution de ces décrets
modifiant ses dispositions du code de la
sécurité intérieure le conseil d'état a
rejeté l'ensemble des recours qui
portait sur la conservation et le
traitement des données relatives à des
opinions politiques des convictions
philosophiques religieuses ou à une
appartenance syndicale
le conseil d'état a considéré que la
collecte et l'accès aux données sont
limités au strict nécessaire et ne porte
pas une atteinte disproportionnée à la
liberté d'opinion de conscience et de
religion ou à la liberté syndicale
le conseil d'état parce qu'il garantit
la légalité des décrets et protecteur
des droits du citoyen est un pilier
central de notre république
nous devons respecter sa décision de
plus la cnil vérifie chaque année et en
contrôle continu que les données
présents dans les différents fichiers
correspondent bien à la finalité de ces
derniers il peut également est rappelé
que ces décrets n'ont pas créé ces
fichiers qui existait déjà il s'agissait
seulement de préciser les catégories en
tirant les conséquences de délibération
de la cnil restituons enfin leur ampleur
les trois fichiers concerne soixante
mille personnes contre 19 millions pour
le fichier de traitement des antécédents
judiciaires par exemple au delà de ces
trois fichiers la pratique de la
collecte de données en englobe beaucoup
d'autres le tess le fpr le casier
judiciaire la sécurité sociale la caf
startrack opéré par tracfin les gâteaux
octopus et bien d'autres nous avons tous
en tête l'abandon du projet edvige
en 2008 il est en effet important de ne
pas tout centraliser et d'avoir des
fichiers distincts et spécifiques pour
chaque type de situation cette diversité
des fichiers et l'encadrement du
recoupement entre eux
garantit les libertés individuelles
chaque service de sécurité publique a le
droit à accéder à certains fichiers mais
pas à d'autres
quand ils peuvent accéder à un fichier
c'est seulement pour un objectif bien
précis
en outre de nombreux fichiers sont
constitués par les entreprises privées
notamment les banques assurances et
depuis quelques années les gars femmes
ces fichiers contiennent des
informations bien plus dé toutes tailles
et est souvent plus personnel que les
fichiers publics
nous devons donc y est particulièrement
attentif et en assurant le contrôle
effectif face à ces nouveaux outils
il est bien sûr essentielle d'étendre le
domaine du droit et de créer des outils
permettant le respect de la vie privée
l'amélioration des démarches de
consultation rectification et de
suppression des données notamment avec
la publication de lettres types
contribuent à cette dynamique là vice
président de la commission européenne et
commissaire européenne à la justice aux
droits fondamentaux et à la citoyenneté
avait posé le 30 novembre 2010 le droit
à l'oubli comme l'une des valeurs et
comme un droit fondamental de l'europe
toutefois je veux le redire ici pour en
revenir aux trois fichiers dont je
parlais il ne s'agit pas d'étiqueter des
personnes selon leur opinion religieuse
syndicale ou politique mais d'identifier
les liens entre les individus ayant
commis des actions violentes disposer de
fichiers qualifiés et détaillée est
essentielle pour que les outils de
renseignements et de sûreté fonctionne
et donc pour que la sécurité publique
soit garanti je crois en tout cas et je
conclurai ainsi que tout débat sur les
fichiers doit mobiliser évidemment notre
vigilance à l'égard des traitements visé
mais également une certaine nuance dans
le propos est l'analyse on regarde les
garanties strictes prévues par notre
droit et notre niveau technique en la
matière je vous remercie
merci la parole est à madame maryse
carrère pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen et pour
cinq minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je commencerais par
remercier nos collègues du groupe crc
eux de nous permettre de nous interroger
aujourd'hui sur les libertés
individuelles et la protection de la vie
privée de nos concitoyens au travers du
fichage c'est d'autant plus important
que la france est plongée dans un état
d'urgence et donc d'exception quasi
permanente depuis la nuit du 13 novembre
loin de moi l'idée de remettre en cause
les raisons pour lesquelles ces lois ont
été votées puis prorogé dans la folie
terroristes qui nous a frappés mérité
une réponse forte mais il est à mon sens
nécessaire d'un perte d' interpeller sur
la vigilance
l'exigence que nous devons avoir
vis-à-vis de ces régimes qui sont hélas
devenu la norme concernant le gym d'état
d'urgence mis en place en 2015 s'il a
pris fin en 2017
force est de constater que nombre de
dispositions sont entrées dans le droit
comme m
une hausse des prérogatives dévolues au
juge administratif au détriment du juge
judiciaire
que ce soit en terme de liberté
surveillée ou bien en cas de fermeture
de lieux de culte si le procédé à
l'avantagé de la rapidité d'exécution il
représente aussi une perte de garantie
pour les justiciables qui ne faut pas
minorer à ces mesures que nous avons
consacré par la loi sylt puis prorogé en
octobre dernier est venu s'ajouter ce
que personne n'aurait imaginé il ya
encore un an
un état d'urgence sanitaire celui ci n'a
que peu de choses en commun avec celui
de 2015 il est beaucoup plus sensible
car c'est l'ensemble de la population
qui voit ses liberté restreinte que ce
soit celle d'aller et venir de réunions
de réunion ou bien même d'entreprendre
c'est toute une vie qui est chamboulée
depuis près d'un an au rythme des
confinement des couvre feux et las des
fermetures administratives cdh à l'aise
à l'instar des mesures antiterroristes
un renforcement du pouvoir du juge
administratif au détriment du juge
judiciaire
ce sont des mesures exceptionnelles
comme les audiences à huis clos pour les
justiciables le recours aux ordonnances
ou encore l'obligation de placement à
l'isolément
c'est enfreignent un enjeu et pas des
moindres celui de nos données
personnelles et don et de la façon dont
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens sont
jumelées
abl face à de nouvelles formes d'
intrusion dans leur vie privée et de
fichage je prendrai l'exemple de
l'application stop qu'ovide rebaptisé
tout senti qu vite qui a connu des
débuts mitigés et de son utilisation qui
s'avère délicate
d'abord parce qu'à ses débuts elle était
peu intuitive qu'elle nécessitait d'être
redémarrer à chaque fois qualité qu'elle
reste très peu télécharger et que quand
bien même elle été téléchargée elle
restait peu utilisé ensuite parce qu'en
dépit de ce que l'on nous avait annoncé
l collecté plus de données que prévu
je vous épargnerai les remarques sur son
incompatibilité avec les systèmes choisi
par nos voisins européens
oui madame la ministre la version tout
senti qu vide est venu apporter en
lisibilité et éteindre certains doutes
mais voilà le projet de modification du
décret du 29 mai 2020 vient ajouter de
nouvelles zones d'ombré sur cette
application est évoqué la possibilité de
scanner des qr codes pour entrer dans
des lieux clos sans que l'on ne sache
rien de ce futur système ni quels lieux
seraient concernés ou même no comment
seraient conservés les données
concernant les données toujours il est
prévu de lancer une collecte anonyme
pourrais je cite l'avis du comité
consultatif de liaison connaître les
données de navigation de l'utilisateur
le temps d'activation moyen du bluetooth
dans la journée le temps d'ouverture
moyen de l'application le nombre de
contacts secours et le nombre de
contacts croiser tout cela sans que l'on
sache pourquoi
comment ni même le but de quoi laisser
quelque peu perplexe perplexe d'autant
plus que ce projet de décret vient
également supprimé la limite du temps à
l'obligation de publication du rapport
sur l'application tout senti qu vite
aujourd'hui ce sont des millions de
données qui circulent chaque jour dans
notre pays des millions d'informations
sur chacun d'entre nous qui sont
collectés pour conclure madame la
ministre vous connaissez l'attachement
du rdr des sceaux aux libertés mais
aussi son sens des responsabilités
lorsqu'il en va de la sécurité de notre
pays
je me permets donc de vous alerter vous
alerter sur le fait que toute
application de liberté si on veut
qu'elle soit consenti doit être limitée
dans le temps
aussi nous émettons le veut qu'à la
sortie de cet état d'urgence sanitaire
nous n'intégrions pas où
de mesures exceptionnelles à notre droit
commun afin de ne pas fragiliser notre
état de droit et que chaque citoyen de
notre pays soit en mesure de savoir où
il est fiché et qu'elles sont la nature
des données qui le concernent connu des
services de l'état où d'autres
je vous remercie mais si la parole est à
madame cathy apourceau poly pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes et pour cinq minutes chers
collègues
si madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
suite à ce qu'a rappelé eliane assassi
je voudrais revenir sur les dangers
d'affichage massif des organisations
syndicales des syndicalistes et des
militants d'un fichage politique de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
je voudrais rappeler la place
essentielle des syndicats et du
mouvement social dans une démocratie
digne de ce nom au moment où la france
est considérée comme démocratie
défaillante
ce rappel est essentiel au moment où il
est toujours plus difficile de
manifester d'exprimer des revendications
pour plus de justice sociale
pourtant la mission des syndicalistes et
la défense des intérêts individuels et
collectifs des salariés ils combattent
la violence des délocalisations des
fermetures d'entreprises de plans qui
n'ont de sociaux que le nom ils
dénoncent les privatisations et
l'abandon de biens publics et de
fleurons industriels à la finance il
lutte contre les licenciements indues
pour la préservation des retraités de
notre système de protection sociale tout
en accompagnant des milliers de salariés
dans la détresse
et pourtant plusieurs d'entre eux ont
été condamnés à des amendes et à de la
prison suite à des actions dans le cadre
de leurs fonctions syndicales
ils ont été condamnés pour s'être opposé
à la politique de casse de leur
entreprise ces condamnations injustes ne
suffisent pas au gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui permet le fichage des
syndicalistes au même titre que de
dangereux délinquants il s'agit
maintenant de stigmatiser la liberté
d'opinion et l'action syndicale
comment justifier que le simple fait
d'être adhérent un syndicat puisse d'une
manière ou d'une autre
porter atteinte à la sécurité intérieure
à la sûreté de l'état à la lutte contre
le terrorisme ou encore selon les termes
des derniers décrets porter atteinte à
l'intégrité du territoire ou les
institutions de la république
comment justifier que le droit à
résister à revendiquer agir puce est
criminelle l'autre point que je voudrais
aborder et la protection des données de
santé de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui ces données sont
particulièrement convoités et sont
devenus un enjeu majeur
ces données sont par définition
particulièrement sensible parce qu'elles
font état de la santé de la personne
mais elles peuvent aussi révélé sa
condition sociale ou d'autres
particularités personnel pire ces
données pourraient être utilisées à des
fins de discrimination refus
d'attribution d'un prêt bancaire d'accès
à un emploi refus de couverture sociale
complémentaire
par exemple en cas de maladie grave hors
la loi ma santé 2022 prévoit la création
d'une plateforme visant à centraliser
l'ensemble des données de santé de
millions de personnes
malgré les risques incontestable que
présente une telle centralisation
ces données qui était considéré comme
une information purement médical dont
l'usagé était limitée aux professionnels
de santé aux services médicaux
administratifs sortent du cadre strict
du cabinet du médecin de l'établissement
de santé pour relever d'un usage plus
collectif en effet le choix de confier
l'hébergement de données qui permettent
de suivre le parcours de santé de 67
millions de personnes sur près de 12
années à microsoft nous interpelle même
si le ministre annoncé il ya peu que cet
hébergement
ne dit on est deux ans suite au recours
évidemment de différentes organisations
devant le conseil d'état ce qui nous
interpelle c'est la justification du
choix initial
pourquoi avoir choisi microsoft alors
même que le conseil d'état souligné
qu'il ne peut être totalement exclu que
les autorités américaines dans le cadre
de programmes de surveillance et de
renseignement demande d'un micro stuff
l'accès à certaines données
d'autant que l'anonymat du patient n'est
pas toujours garanti ce qui peut
encourager des acteurs tiers tels que
des employeurs des assureurs et des
organismes bancaires
à tenter d'accéder à ses données dans un
objectif de profit
comment croire que deux ans ne seront
pas suffisants pour que les données
pourtant couvertes par le secret médical
soient bradés ou accaparés par des
intérêts commerciaux ou politique
enfin depuis l'accord national
interprofessionnel de 2013 qui a
généralisé les complémentaires santé
obligatoire dans les entreprises à
ouvrir aux assureurs l'axé privé au
fichier des données de santé des
salariés
les données des réseaux de santé gérés
par les complémentaires ne sont pas
protégés et cela entraîne des risques
importants pour le respect de la vie
privée l'existence des fichiers dans la
société a dans le passé conduit à la
démission du gouvernement emile combes
en 1905
suite à la faire des fiches qui
recensait justement les opinions
politiques syndicales et religieuses des
officiers
la généralisation des fichiers dans la
société ses conséquences pour garantir
le respect des libertés individuelles
sont les faits nouveaux qui nécessite
selon nous transparence et démocratie
merci merci
la parole est à mme c'est loïc hervé
pour le groupe union centriste et pour
huit minutes chers collègues
madame le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues jamais en temps de
paix nous n'auront autant atteintes aux
libertés publiques les plus essentiels
comme la liberté d'aller et venir où la
liberté du commerce et de l'industrie
pour la bonne cause me direz vous car
comme le rappelle le premier ministre
il y à une pandémie qui touche la france
mais dans cette période d'état d'urgence
sanitaire alors que nos préoccupations
sont toutes orientées vers la gestion de
la crise pandémique et de ses
conséquences économiques et sociales
nous devons mes chers collègues toujours
avoir à coeur de préserver les acquis
démocratiques que notre histoire
politique et notre doctrine juridique
nous ont légué
selon une étude récente de économistes
les libertés démocratiques ont reflué
dans près de 70% des pays du moins en
un chiffre élevé qui amène à se poser de
nombreuses interrogations surtout quand
la france se retrouve dans la catégorie
des démocraties défaillante
c'est pourquoi je rends grâce au groupe
crc un de nous permettre de réfléchir en
forme ce soir à six questions
essentielles et de ne pas nous laisser
emporter par le plus grave de tous les
risques celui des accommodements
raisonnables
pire celui de l'accoutumance quand le
numérique envahir rapports sociaux et
avec une vitesse incroyable avec des
acteurs privés aussi puissante des états
se pose toujours cette question avec une
grande acuité de savoir comment toujours
mieux protéger les libertés publiques et
la vie privée quand il faut même moment
lutter contre le terrorisme ou un virus
légiférons nous dans le bon sens et avec
bon sens lorsque lors du projet le
silence pour 2019
nous avons voté au parlement la capacité
pour l'administration fiscale d'aller
chaluter des données qui ne sont pas
moins personnel au motif qu'elles sont
publiques
cette tendance préoccupante très
préoccupant de nous tous nous aussi
législateur motivés que nous sommes
parfois de vouloir une administration
plus efficace qui prévient mieux les
crimes les délits et la fraude mais que
faisons-nous de la vie privée comme en
préservant nous ce droit essentiel qui
est chahuté dans ses fondements mêmes
par les évolutions sociologiques devrait
vous rappeler ce qu'est la protection de
la vie privée affirmé en 1948 par la
déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme qui était rationnement droit
français à l'article 9 du code civil qui
dispose que toute personne a droit au
respect de sa vie privée et pour
rappeler aussi quand de 1999
plusieurs décisions du conseil
constitutionnel sont venus étend la
protection évoqué le respect des
libertés publiques et de la vie privée
mes chers collègues nous amène
naturellement à nous saisir de la
question de l'utilisation des fichiers
de la collecte de données qui se lèvent
aujourd'hui de multiples interrogations
juridiques au sens de la loi dite
informatique et libertés du 6 janvier
ces fichiers constituent des traitements
automatisés données personnelles et font
l'objet d'une réglementation spécifique
même si le même si l'intitulé de notre
débat est bien plus large
je me concentrerai sur les fichiers de
police et de renseignement catégorie à
part entière au sein des fichiers
administratifs ils restent spécifiques
quant à leur finalité qui est de
participer au maintien de l'ordre public
cette spécificité des situe ainsi à la
frontière entre la répression et la
prévention
d'une part ils sont chargés de collecter
des données pour prévenir des atteintes
à l'ordre public
quand d'autre part ils peuvent être la
source de l'action répressive de l'état
nos concitoyens et plus largement le
débat public dans notre pays ont
malheureusement commencé à s'intéresser
à ces fichiers est alors finalité en
particulier celle des fameuses fiches s
lors des attentats terroristes survenus
depuis 2015 l'utilisation efficace de
ces fichiers a souvent termine réaction
rapide dans la recherche des auteurs
tout en facilitant l'action répressive
mais a entraîné un débat sur la capacité
de l'autorité publique à les utiliser de
façon préventive
ces outils traitement de données
utilisées dans le cadre du maintien de
l'ordre ne sont pas sans contrôle notre
pays dispose aujourd'hui d'un corpus
juridique solide qui encadre strictement
l'utilisation de ces fichiers et qui a
maintenant plus d'une quarantaine
d'années ayant la chance d'y siéger
depuis à présent six ans et d'entamer un
deuxième mandat depuis quelques jours il
m'est impossible de ne pas évoquer le
rôle crucial de la commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés en la
matière en effet ces fichiers de police
font l'objet d'un contrôle préalable
par la cnil se traduisant par la
formulation d'un avis motivé et publiée
sur l'ensemble des projets de création
de ces fichiers
madame la ministre à l'occasion de ce
débat ce soir au sénat je dois aussi
d'insister sur leurs oeuvres
incontournables du parlement alors que
le pouvoir exécutif continue de disposer
de pouvoirs élargis
y compris le pouvoir de légiférer par
ordonnance dans tout un tas de domaines
et je ne voudrais pas être inutilement
polémique mais nous allons étudier dans
le mois prochain le texte dit sécurité
globale ce texte a été écrit sans étude
d'impact et sans avis du conseil d'état
et bien ce texte fera l'objet d'une
première pour la première fois depuis
que la loi l'a autorisé en 2018
le président la commission des lois du
sénat a saisi la cnil d'une demande
d'avis sur l'ensemble du texte
et cet avis vient de nous être rendus
pour la cnil le cadre juridique de ce
texte contient plusieurs dispositions
intéressant directement la protection
des données personnelles au travers en
particulier la modification du cadre
juridique applicable en matière de vidéo
et de réglementation des caméras est
reportée dans le langage courant les
drones n'est pas en l'état suffisamment
protecteur de la vie privée et des
données personnelles
il nous faudra être attentif à cela lors
de nos discussions et j'irai
personnellement puisque je suis l'un des
deux co rapporteur de ce texte
le débat d'aujourd'hui nous donne
l'occasion d'évoquer la décision rendue
par le conseil d'état le 4 janvier
dernier
saisi en référé par plusieurs
organisations syndicales en raison d'un
risque de surveillance de masse la plus
haute juridiction administrative du pays
est venu valider trois décrets
autorisant les forces de l'ordre à
ficher les opinions politiques les
convictions philosophiques et
religieuses et l'appartenance syndicale
plusieurs collègues l'ont évoquée avant
moi cc ce fichage a lieu avant le
recrutement de fonctionnaires sur des
postes sensibles désormais pourront être
recensé les données de toutes personnes
soupçonnées d'activités terroristes ou
susceptible je cite de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité du territoire et des
institutions de la république
la terminologie retenue reprend
d'ailleurs celle du r j et de la loi
que nous avons
débattue et votée ici notons que j'ai
décrit avait fait l'objet en amont d'une
consultation de la cnil qui avait donné
son accord à l'application de ses déclas
destiné notamment à lutter contre le
terrorisme
mes chers collègues force est de
constater que dans la période que nous
vivons sur à peu près tous les sujets
nous avons un recul des libertés
publiques
alors qu'elles sont toujours elles
doivent l'être car antilles par notre
constitution
plus que jamais le rôle des magistrats
judiciaires et administratifs ou
l'existence d' autorité administrative
indépendante comme la cnil constitue une
force et une vigie pour nos libertés
et sachez madame la ministre que pour
protéger les libertés publiques et la
vie privée nous serons toujours au
rendez vous c'est le devoir et c'est
l'honneur du sénat merci la parole est à
monsieur jérôme durain pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et pour cinq minutes chers collègues ne
tombez pas dans les escaliers
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues je tiens d'abord à
remercier le groupe crc eux pour ce
débat sur le nécessaire état des lieux
des fichiers de notre pays respect des
libertés publiques protection de la vie
privée
voilà les principes qui oriente notre
discussion de ce soir ce sont des
principes largement partagée à droite
comme à gauche car tout le monde sait
que le sénat est une institution
profondément attaché à la défense des
libertés publiques
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains avaient d'ailleurs demandé
l'audition du ministre d'intérieur par
la commission des lois sur les fichiers
police dès le 11 décembre et le
président du fait et de ce fait dans le
remercier avait donné une suite
favorable à cette demande ce qui nous a
permis effectivement d'entendre le
ministre le 12 janvier dernier
mais je vais avoir l'occasion d'y
revenir alors comme citoyen nous sommes
tous fichés de gré ou de force
et s'il peut être bon de bon ton de
s'opposer au principe même du fichage il
faut rappeler que nous nous fichons
souvent volontairement et dans nos
collègues l'a rappelé tout à l'heure qui
s'il n'a pas adhéré à un parti politique
créé son compte google demandé sa carte
de sécurité sociale
personne évidemment il faut d'ailleurs
reconnaître que nous sommes tous bien
moins regardant avec les fichiers
détenus par des tiers privés qu'avec les
fichiers détenus par l'état
cela s'explique rares sont les
entreprises avoir pris le contrôle de
pays créer leur propre police et
enfermer des gens selon leurs
convictions personnelles
a contrario il n'est pas rare que des
états dépassent le cadre qu'il s'était
fixé il n'est pas rare que des états et
des police et des prisons à leur
disposition cela ne signifie pas que
l'on doive s'opposer au principe du
fichage par les états le maintien de
l'ordre public
l'accès aux soins de tous la lutte
contre le terrorisme sont des
justifications qu'on ne peut nier mais
c'est ce nécessaire antagonisme entre
les besoins d'état et la défense par les
individus des libertés publiques qui
fait l'honneur de nos démocraties
le ministre de l'intérieur doit accepter
que les citoyens soient réticents au
fichage et les citoyens doivent accepter
que l'état satisfasse son besoin
d'outils à la protection de la société
si je me permets ces rappels passé parce
que je
lors de l'audition de monsieur darmana
en janvier j'avais indiqué vous me
pardonnerez cette citation que ces
fichiers semble de nature à entretenir
un climat qui n'est pas sain en donnant
le sentiment de contrevenir aux libertés
publiques
monsieur darmanin m'avait répondu un peu
courroucé
je ne peux pas laisser dire que les
décrets contreviennent aux libertés
publiques
au delà de la joute oratoire je tiens à
dire au ministre en général au
gouvernement qui l'a le blake
l'obligation de laisser dire aux
parlementaires tout ce qu'ils veulent
pour ma part j'ai été étonné dans sa
réponse d'alors par l'interprétation
qu'il a fait de l'avis de la cnil
ainsi monsieur darmanin a déclaré devant
la commission des lois les fichiers ont
été validés par le conseil d'état et la
cnil en amont et de nouveau par le
conseil d'état en aval ils sont d'autant
plus respectueux des libertés publiques
qu'ils ont été conçus à la demande de la
cnil
alors il se trouve que la commission des
lois a aussi auditionné la présidente de
la cnil
madame marie laure denis la semaine
dernière cette dernière a déclaré c'est
au compte rendu de la commission des
lois que une évolution sémantique a eu
lieu
on est passés d'activités politiques
religieuses philosophiques et syndicales
à des opinions politiques des
convictions philosophiques et
religieuses et l'appartenance syndicale
les mis en gras dans mon texte la cnil
n'a pas été consulté sur cette
modification sémantique car les textes
ont évolué depuis notre avis je rappelle
c'est toujours marie laure denis qui
parle
je rappelle que la cnil n'autorise pas
ou ne refuse pas les textes sur lesquels
elles émettent un avis celui ci vise à
éclairer le pouvoir réglementaire ou le
législateur et il appartient au juge
administratif de se prononcer sur la
légalité des actes réglementaires
en l'espèce le conseil d'état s'est
prononcé en référer sans déceler de
doute sérieux sur la légalité du texte
mais il aura très certainement à se
prononcer au fond en tout cas et la
présidente conclut le collège de la cnil
ne s'est pas prononcé sur l'évolution
sémantique peut-être le gouvernement
souhaitera-t-il répondre à cette
déclaration de la présidente de la cnil
quoi qu'il en soit on le voit
il faut débattre de ces questions
relatives aux fichiers merci au groupe
crc eux et ma collègue annie le houérou
apportera d'autres aspects qui sont
liées aux fichiers de sentiers tout
aussi important et qui intéresse aussi
fortement les français la parole est à
monsieur yves bouloux pour le groupe
l'est républicain et pour sept minutes
chers collègues
mais la présidente à la ministre un
échec collègues la conciliation entre le
droit de l'individu et le droit de la
société entre l'ordre du public et la
liberté n'est pas un problème récent en
droit français
l'article 9 du code civil dispose que
toute personne a droit au respect de sa
vie privée
à l'origine de cette demande de débat on
retrouve les trois décrets du 4 décembre
2020 et la tribune publiée le 17
décembre dernier dans le journal
libération extension des fichiers de
renseignements un nouveau danger pour
nos libertés
cette tribune signée par de nombreux
élus de gauche et écologistes de nom
c'est l'atteinte à la démocratie et le
prg et le mépris du parlement s'il
s'agissait bien d'une compétence
réglementaires et non législative
l'élaboration de ces décrets on est
effectivement toutefois pu donner lieu à
une consultation du parlement ou à tout
le moins à une communication
au lieu de cela les parlementaires en
ont appris l'existence par voie de
presse après leur publication
une tête manière de procéder est
incompréhensible
elle l'est d'autant plus que lorsque
l'on se souvient des débats suscités à
part le décret edwige en deux en juin
ce décret crée un fichier recensant des
personnes ayant sollicité exercé ou
exerçant un mandat politique syndical ou
économique ou qui jouent un rôle
institutionnel économique social ou
religieux significatif
il fut finalement retiré au mois de
novembre suivant
ce manque de transparence nourrit
malheureusement les suspicions envers
l'état de droit aujourd'hui via les
réseaux sociaux tout le monde des
fichiers par des big brothers privé
sans rien y trouver à redire le constat
est sans appel pour les français il est
aujourd'hui plus facile de s'inscrire
sur facebook ou instagram que de
télécharger l'application antique vide
cette différence édifiant ce pardon de
l'état doit interpeller la menace
terroriste faisant l'état est de plus en
plus incapable de garantir la sécurité
sans entraver la liberté
si le fichage étatiques et frais c'est
en raison des conséquences que l'état
pourrait en tirer
mais le fichage est parfois nécessaire
et certains fichiers ne seront jamais
contesté on peut citer pour exemple le
fichier des auteurs d'infractions
sexuelles ou violentes ou encore celui
sur les agréments des assistantes
maternelles dans la création vient
d'être annoncée la sécurité n'est pas
une liberté mais bien l'une des
conditions de leur exercice
pourquoi serré c'est assez récent créé
d'écran pardon décret interpelle parce
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans une logique de
prévention des risques
il s'agit d'un fichage d'opinion de
conscience et non de comportement
répréhensible c'est décret prévoit en
effet la création de fichiers de police
pouvant contenir des données relatives à
des opinions politiques des convictions
philosophiques religieuses ou une
appartenance syndicale ainsi que des
données de santé auraient bel ont une
dangerosité particulière
le premier est le fichier et aspect
enquêtes administratives liées à la
sécurité publique
utilisée avant le recrutement de
fonctionnaires sur des postes sensibles
il s'agit d'éviter de recruter des
personnes potentiellement dangereuses ou
radicaliser
deux autres fichiers sont le pass
prévention des atteintes à la sécurité
publique et le gip aspect gestion de
forme d'information et prévention des
atteintes à la sécurité publique l'un le
pass est géré par la police l'autre le
gie passe par les gendarmes ils traitent
tous les deux des informations liées aux
atteintes à la sécurité de l'état
il s'agit de permettre à la police ou à
la gendarmerie de faciliter leur enquête
soumis pour avis à la commission
nationale des libertés la cnil
ils font l'objet de retour de recours
contentieux
le 4 janvier dernier le conseil d'état a
jugé qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
prononcer leur suspension
selon le juge des référés la collecte de
ces données dans les traitements
litigieux n'entraîne pas d' atteinte
grave et manifestement illégale au droit
au respect de la ville de la vie privée
ou à la liberté d'opinion
deux arguments retenu son attention
d'une part seuls les activités
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
sécurité publique ou à la sûreté de
l'état pourront donner lieu pour deux
pourront donner lieu à l'enregistrement
de données
d'autre part il sera interdit de
sélectionner dans le traitement une
catégorie particulière de personnes à
partir des seules données sensibles
jusqu'au jugement au fond de ces
affaires
ces fichiers sont donc légaux mais tout
ce qui est légal est il souhaitable
la question que l'on peut légitimement
se poser et en quoi le fait de
ficher des opinions y compris
philosophique peut garantir la bonne
tenue d'une manifestation l'élargît
élargir le fichage c'est de considérer
que des opinions puissent représenter un
danger en elle-même cela représente une
rupture importante et inquiétante dans
la matinée dans la manière de penser la
sûreté de l'état en 2009
robert de la bad à terre déplorait déjà
le recours presque obsessionnelle à des
fichiers et s'interroger de cette dérive
inquiétante sites passés d'une justice
de liberté à une justice de sûreté un
tel changement de doctrine ne peut être
acceptée que si l'on peut s'assurer de
son utilisation et de son effectivité
pourra-t-on s'assurer que les personnes
fichées seront pleinement informés et
auront accès à leur droit de
rectification
quelles conséquences légales sont
retirés de ces fichiers
pourront-ils justifier une arrestation
ou un non recrutement
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame annie le houérou pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et pour quatre minutes chers collègues
la présidente madame la ministre à chers
collègues la pandémie mondiale l'aco
vide de 19 a vu émerger la prolifération
de virus et de virus d'un autre type de
virus informatiques les établissements
de santé les laboratoires de diagnostic
ou de recherche sont régulièrement
victimes de piratage les données de
santé sont très prisés récupérer elles
sont revendus à prix d'or un titre
d'exemple la société moderne a été
touché par une cyberattaque en juillet
dernier astrazeneca on a été victime en
novembre
plus récemment en janvier l'agencé
européenne de médecine confirme qu'une
version falsifié les fichiers volés chez
pfizer a bien été partagés sur le dap
koepp lagnes il a publié en janvier un
avis sur plusieurs mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement dans le cadre
de la crise sanitaire
cet avis a mis en évidence plusieurs
manquements dans la gestion des données
de données personnelles notamment sur
leur durée de conservation et leur
sécurité dans son logiciel dédié aux
contacts aux contacts racing pour la
cnil bien que prévu par une circulaire
ministérielle ce processus le tracking
entraîne une dispersion des données dans
les messageries
de plus ces informations en partie
stockées sur les serveurs sont conserver
trop longtemps
faisons fi du règlement général de
protection des données personnelles
s'agissant de l'application stop
qu'ovide devenu touchant tiko vite en
octobre 2020 la cnil avait estimé que le
dispositif était conforme au règlement
général de la protection des données
mais elle estimait que l'application ne
pouvait être déployée que si son utilité
pour la gestion de la crise était
suffisamment avérées et si certaines
garanties étaient apportées son
utilisation devait être temporaire et
les données devaient être conservés
pendant une durée limitée
insidieusement tout senti qu vite tant
vers les mêmes travers sans vigilance
particulière sur la durée et sur les
conditions de stockage des infos
personnelles
les appels à la vigilance sont nombreux
en janvier 2021
christian babusiaux l'ancien président
de l'aci
des données de santé appelait le
gouvernement à rompre hawk vite
le contrat conclu avec microsoft pour la
construction d'un grand entrepôt
d'hébergement des données de santé
les doutes sur les 46 offertes par le
droit américain font craindre pour la
sécurité des données de santé des
français avec un risque d'exploitation
abusive de ces dernières si le
gouvernement s'est engagé à retirer
l'hébergement de ces données à microsoft
d'ici deux ans ce délai trop long au
regard des risques d'exploitation des
données à d'autres fins que celles pour
lesquelles elles ont été communiquées
enfin en décembre le gouvernement avait
présenté un projet de loi instaurant un
régime pérenne de gestion des urgences
sanitaires
l'article premier de ce texte prévoyait
de conditionner le déplacement des
personnes et l'exercice de certaines
activités à la présentation d'un test de
dépistage ou au suivi d'un traitement
préventif y compris la vaccination
en d'autres termes c'est la mise en
place d'un passeport d' sanitaires si le
projet de loi depuis été retirée et son
examen renvoyé après la sortie de la
crise une telle mesure doit être
envisagée avec la plus grande prudence
nous veillerons au respect des libertés
individuelles le parlement est garant de
cette protection
en s'appuyant sur les avis de la cnil
dans son avis la cnil rappelle ainsi que
les données de santé sont protégés par
le secret médical et ne doivent être
traitées que par les personnes
habilitées est soumise au secret
professionnel
vous l'avez compris madame la ministre
la protection des données personnelles
est un enjeu majeur a fortiori les
données personnelles de santé
elles doivent être strictement protégée
pour garantir la liberté de chacun ces
données statistiques destiné à une
exploitation collective pour la
recherche l'industrie sont
particulièrement convoités et font
l'objet d'espionnage industriel ou de
sabotage malveillants il est de votre
responsabilité et de celle du
gouvernement de les protéger
efficacement de veiller à ce que leur
utilisation ne soit pas dévoyé de
garantir notre indépendance nationale en
la matière protéger ces données c'est
protéger les français mais aussi le
nôtre
6 le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains sera particulièrement
vigilant quant à la création de fichiers
dans notre pays et en particulier ceux
liés à l'utilisation cher s'orienter qui
tendent à se généraliser notamment je
pense au dossier médical personnage mais
si pour terminer ce débat la parole et à
madame marlène schiappa ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté taf ou madame
la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis heureuse de la tenue de ces travaux
est de pouvoir participer à vos échanges
à votre débat très riche sur ce sujet
fondamental autour du respect des
libertés publiques de la protection de
la vie privée et du nécessaire est à des
lieues des fichiers dans notre pays
avant de pouvoir réagir aux divers
propos et je l'espère apporter des
réponses aux questions qui ont été
posées ce soir et aux observations qui
ont été formulées je voudrais partager
avec vous quelques éléments d'abord dans
la décennie passée nous avons connu vous
savez trois mouvements majeurs en termes
de fichiers sécurité en apparence
contradictoires mais que nous avons
pourtant voulu et je l'espère su
concilier premièrement un contexte
sécuritaire qui s'est globalement tendu
avec une menace terroriste qui est
désormais structurantes
deuxièmement des évolutions techniques
et technologiques qui ouvre de nouvelles
potentialités en termes de traitement de
données
et troisièmement un droit des données
qui n'a cessé de s'étoffer et de se
préciser avec notamment à l'entrée en
vigueur dans notre droit du règlement
général de protection des données 2018
via sa transcription dans la loi
informatique et libertés que vous
connaissez bien
c'est de ce triple mouvement qui est
issue la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et qui se caractérise me
semble-t-il d'abord par de nouveaux
besoins de services de sécurité en
termes d'accès aux fichiers
d'interconnexion de fiabilisation des
identités des personnes inscrites de
l'exigence accrue de transparence et
cela a été mentionné à plusieurs
reprises de précisions sur chacun des
fichiers sur leur finalité sur leurs
modalités de fonctionnement sur les
mesures prises pour s'assurer que ne
sont collectées et conservées que les
données strictement nécessaire et
seulement elle
j'observe qu'il ya une forme d'exigences
contradictoires vis-à-vis de l'état et
cela a été dit également les français et
c'est d'ailleurs heureux sont de plus en
plus sensibilisés aux enjeux de leurs
données et du traitement qui peut en
être fait il soit aussi parfois méchant
vis-à-vis de fichiers mise en oeuvre par
l'état et singulièrement par le
ministère de l'intérieur
mais dans le même temps il me semble que
les français attendent aussi des
policiers des gendarmes si le fils
anticiper prévenir les menaces agir
détectée dès que possible les individus
potentiellement dangereux travail
quotidien pour lequel le recours au
fichier est bien souvent et chacun le
comprend indispensable à cet égard la
demande croissante de pouvoir mener des
enquêtes administratives sur des
personnes qui exercent des métiers
sensible de la sécurité mais aussi de
l'enseignement de la santé des services
publics est révélatrice
dans ce contexte nous avons fait le
choix en france de conserver un régime
de fichiers de sécurité très protecteur
en effet alors que l'eire gpd et la
directive police-justice de 2018 qui
régit les fichiers dont nous sommes en
train de débattre ce soir on s'initie un
vrai changement de paradigme notamment
en supprimant le régime de déclaration
d'autorisation des fichiers et bien nous
avons fait le choix de maintenir un
régime d'autorisation pour les fichiers
de sécurité ce qui signifie que tout
traitement de données à caractère
personnel qui intéresse la sûreté de
l'état
la défense ou la sécurité publique ou
qui a pour objet la prévention la
recherche la constatation la poursuite
des infractions pénales
l'exécution de ces condamnations des
mesures de sûreté et bien doit être
autorisée par un acte règlementaire prix
après un avis de la cnil
parmi ces traitements ce qui porte sur
des données dites sensibles je pense aux
données biométriques sont
particulièrement encadrée puisqu'ils
doivent être à chaque fois autorisé par
décret en conseil d'état pris après avis
de la cnil est d'ailleurs les décrets à
qt est évoquée relève d'actualisation
sémantique sur ces questions et je tiens
à le préciser
chacun des fichiers du ministère de
l'intérieur doit donc respecter des
dispositions cardinal du droit de zoomer
personnel à savoir elles doivent être
collectées et traitées de manière loyale
est licite ses principes de l'égalité
elles doivent être collectées pour des
finalités déterminé explicite et
légitime le principe de finalité le
responsable d'un traitement ne peut
enregistrer ou utiliser des informations
sur des personnes physiques que dans un
but précis légales et légitimes elles
doivent être adéquates pertinentes non
excessives au regard des finalités
poursuivies ces principes de
proportionnalité et de pertinence les
informations enregistrées doivent être
donc strictement nécessaire au regard de
la finalité données connues du fichier
elles doivent être exact évidemment tenu
à jour et toutes les mesures
nabe doivent être prises pour que les
données à caractère personnel qui sont
inexactes
eu égard aux finalités pour lesquelles
elles sont traitées puisse être et fall
fait ou rectifier et ce sans tarder
elles doivent enfin être conservés sous
une forme qui permet l'identification
des personnes concernées pendant une
durée qui n'excède pas celle nécessaire
au regard des finalités pour lesquelles
elles sont traitées les personnes
disposent également de leurs droits
vis-à-vis de ces fichiers et je
répondais à monsieur le sénateur yves
bouloux les personnes respectent dispose
pardon de leurs droits qu'ils doivent
être respectés droit d'accès de
rectification d'effacement et droits y
compris de saisir la cnil bien sûr
gratuitement pour faire respecter ces
droits là concrètement à chaque fois que
ministère de l'intérieur envisage de
créer le plus souvent de modifier un
traitement de données à caractère
personnel
il doit d'abord prouver à la cnil fille
prouver au conseil d'état ensuite que le
traitement qu'il envisage de mettre en
oeuvre respecte tous ses grands
principes que j'évoquais et j'ajoute que
deux parlementaires sont membres de la
cnil ce qui permet à d'exercer un
contrôle
pour ce faire il doit notamment réalisé
une analyse d'impact relative à la
protection des données qui expose
d'ailleurs très précisément ce qu'il
veut faire les dispositions à la fois
juridique et organiseront
organisationnel pardon fait prendra pour
assurer que seules les données
nécessaires pour la finalité soient
collectées dans le respect de motif
légitime que j'évoquais précédemment
il doit ensuite assurer un droit à
l'information le droit d'accès que
j'évoquais également à modifier même
d'anchamps d'ailleurs de la directive
police justice est important de le
préciser
une fois le fichier validé par la cnil
et par le conseil d'état il a par
ailleurs il est par ailleurs l'objet de
contrôle constant et ce pendant toute sa
durée du contrôle qualité
d'abord en interne obligatoire au regard
des exigences qui pèse sur chaque
responsable de traitement contrôle
externe par la cnil qui mène aussi
régulièrement des contrôles sur les
traitements de police et de gendarmerie
vous le savez bien contrôle du juge
le conseil d'état en l'occurrence qui
est saisi de nombreux recours
contentieux
dans ce contexte juridique en pleine
mutation les auteurs du rapport
d'information de la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale en 2018
consacré aux fichiers sécurité
intérieure saluer justement et je les
cite la diffusion au sein de la police
comme de la gendarmerie
véritable culture des libertés
individuelles donc notre enjeu
aujourd'hui et demain je crois qu'il est
bien là respecter pleinement un droit
exigeant un droit protecteur des données
des libertés publiques tout en donnant
aux services les moyens de leur action
et d'être pertinent et réactif je
voudrais préciser que nous parlons là de
60 cents et les personnes c'est à dire
bien moins que le chiffre de 1 sur 11
qui a été évoquée plus haut je crois que
c'est fondamental le miz l'inter
d'ailleurs l'avait évoqué lors de sa
dernière est récente audition est à cet
égard il avait aussi dit sur le décret
que la cnil avait validé le décret par
facilité de langage pour s'approprier un
langage que les commentateurs utilise
dans le vocable courant alors pourquoi
avoir changé la précédente rédaction qui
parlait à d'activités politiques
religieuses syndicales pour les termes
opinions politiques convictions
philosophiques religieuses et
l'appartenance syndicale d'abord je veux
dire que je ne lutte pas la question
elle est importante je voudrais préciser
la qu'il s'agit d'une demande du conseil
d'état lorsqu'il a examiné le projet de
décret il a demandé au gouvernement dont
ce n'était pas l'objectif initial de
procéder à une évolution terminologique
pour mieux tenir compte de la rédaction
actuelle de la loi informatique et
libertés qui désigne les données
sensibles et j'espère apporter une
réponse à monsieur le sénateur jérôme
durain à cet égard en effet jusqu'à
présent il était précisé que par
exception à l'interdiction de collecter
des données sensibles pouvait être
collectées dans ses fiches et des
données concernant les activités
politiques religieux syndicale la
traduction française du rgp day en
retenue pour qualifier des données
sensibles les termes de opinion
production appartenance le conseil
d'état a très simplement souhaité
aligner cette rédaction
ces éléments ils peuvent être importants
pour contextualiser la menace le fait
qu'un individu adhère par exemple à des
thèses antispécistes est important pour
contextualiser des faits de dégradations
de commerces ou de sites de production
alimentaire auquel il incite à
participer c'est une contextualisations
de même le militantisme n'est évidemment
pas en soi une donnée intéressant les
services aux regards dans l'engagement
syndical
il est en revanche important de savoir
c'est un ange
un des individus par mon radicaliser et
représentant par exemple d'un personnel
de l'entreprise parce qu'il peut dans ce
cas jouit d'une influence plus forte
auprès de ses collègues pour les inciter
par exemple à rejoindre des idéologies
prônant la violence voire un passage à
l'acte
l'examen par le conseil d'état
intervenant après l'examen par la cnil
il est me semble-t-il normal qu'elle ne
se soit pas prononcé d'ailleurs sur
cette évolution
les décrets et précise explicitement qu
aucune recherche dans les fichiers ne
peut être réalisée à partir de ces
données sensibles
je crois que c'est très clair le
gouvernement pardon le gouvernement ne
permet pas le fichage des syndicalistes
appartenir à un syndicat en foi n'est
jamais une raison qui justifie en
séchage et si possible maintenant de
recourir à la reconnaissance faciale
dans ses fichiers la question a été
abordée et je tiens à y répondre
clairement parce que de la même manière
ainsi que la cnil l'a dit elle même dans
son communiqué du 11 décembre
aucun aucun dispositif de reconnaissance
faciale n'est prévu aucun dispositif de
requêtage par photographie n'est
d'ailleurs possible de la même manière
je voudrais ajouter que les moins de 13
ans ne peuvent pas être fichés et c'est
heureux un membre du conseil d'état est
d'ailleurs dédié à la vérification est
remis chaque année un rapport sur ce
sujet et j'espère répondre là
l'interpellation de madame la sénatrice
à ça si il n'y a pas non plus
d'interconnexions automatique dans les
différents fichiers
il peut y avoir des rapprochements
manuel mais rien est automatisée et pas
d'interconnexion entre différents
fichiers qui ont des buts différents
jeux répond là monsieur le sénateur un
max brisson
je voudrais également précisé que ce ne
sont pas toutes les personnes du monde
politique ou syndicale qui peuvent être
fiché comme je le disais précédemment
je crois que il ya peut-être une une
confusion ou en tout cas on évoque par
lé projet actuel on évoque là le projet
edvige qui était envisagé en 2008 qui
n'a jamais vu le jour
ce sont véritablement seules les
personnes qui représentent une menace
grave pour la sécurité qui peuvent être
fichés et bien évidemment pas l'ensemble
des acteurs du champ syndical politique
ou même économique monsieur le sénateur
paul paris dit comme l'a souligné
d'ailleurs madame la sénatrice nicole
jeu rencontrera justement les fichiers
et les données que nous offrons tous les
jours à google ou à différents acteurs
sont bien plus sensible bien plus
personnel et bien en contrôle et je
voudrais préciser pour terminer que des
personnes morales peuvent à l'évidence
représenter une menace pour la sécurité
publique c'est l'objet d'ailleurs du
projet de loi pour conforter les
principes républicains qui arrivera
bientôt en discussion au sénat
les associations violente les
groupements de fait et les gangs
si vous me passez l'expression des
groupes criminels les groupes sectaires
mais dans ce cas le fichage il se fait
au travers des individus qui la
composent ne figureront pas donc comme
élément d'évaluation de la menace que
représente un individu mais le fait
qu'un individu par exemple participe à
des réunions d'un groupe néonazi et bien
cela constitue en soi une information un
élément d'appréciation de sa potentielle
dangerosité de mails il peut être
important de signaler qu'un individu
présentant une menace fait partie d'une
association d'un groupement quelconque
pour déterminer par exemple son
potentiel cercle d' influence ses
relations ses tentatives d'ailleurs
parfois d'entrisme ou de déstabilisation
et je crois qu'en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste c'est
absolument fondamental que de pouvoir
disposer de ces informations est très
précieux pour les forces de sécurité
intérieures par ailleurs concernant
l'application tout senti qu zut je
répond madame la sénatrice carrère et
madame la sénatrice apourceau poly je
tiens à préciser que les données de
santé font exclusivement partie des
données qui sont gérés traiter
exclusivement via le ministère de la
santé
elles ne sont elles ne servent pas au
ministère de l'intérieur ce sont des
données très sensibles qui ont le plus
haut niveau de sensibilité de sécurité
elles font l'objet de mesures de
sécurité très particulière derrière pour
que nul ne puisse y accéder et s'en
servir ça me semble fondamental de le
préciser dans la période de pandémie que
nous traversons il n'y a pas de
l'utilisation de ces données par le
ministère de l'intérieur aucune dans
aucune façon voilà soyez en certain à
certaines mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et les sénatrices le
gouvernement partage votre attachement
fondamental aux libertés publiques et
partagent également
votre attachement j'en suis certaine à
l'efficacité des services de
renseignements des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour mieux nous protéger tout
en respectant le fondamental libertés
publiques qui sont les nôtres et qui
font les grandes heures de la démocratie
je vous remercie
[Musique]